this month the clark county school
district allowed spring sports to resume
while many teams began competing on the
16th
the sierra vista high school baseball
team will miss its first game due to a
positive cobig 19 test
reporter kate houston shares why parents
are now asking the district to
reconsider their testing protocols
tonight the sierra vista mountain lion
should be gearing up for their first
game in more than a year it was exciting
to get the go ahead to come back to the
baseball field for the boys it was
exciting for me to drop my son off
and say hey i'll see you in four hours
for practice but due to a positive
covid19 test last week
the baseball diamond will remain empty
had everything ready
and just to see the the sadness
another letdown parents tara gaber and
j.r starkis are frustrated with the
district
saying the student in question had no
symptoms and retested negative
twice just days later what is it about
this test the school is administering
that is the end-all be-all why after two
negative tests can
can they not you know take a look at it
at least
and say hey listen maybe we had a false
positive ccsd guidelines state in part
that a student athlete who has tested
positive for covid19
must quarantine for 10 days they can get
another test on day five
if it's negative and they continue to be
asymptomatic through day seven
they can return on day eight but by that
point starkis says the team will already
miss another game
and crucial practice time the 12-game
season seems to be cut down already to
like six or eight games
just because of one test gaber says her
son allen is one of many seniors on the
team and this will impact their future
opportunities
how do they you know get committed or go
to the next level
or you know that that's what it's about
you know
it's serious kate houston 8 news now
now kate asked ccsd about their testing
protocols they say they're following
guidelines set by local health officials
and will err on the side of caution